comme c'est beau
[Rires]
la dernière fois que je suis allé chez
le médecin je me suis demandé ce que
faisait ses serpents sur les logos de
quasiment tous les toubibs de la planète
on les retrouve même sur les pharmacies
c'est quoi le lien entre les serpents et
la médecine alors bien sûr vous dites
bah oui mais moi je le savais c'est le
serpent d'Esculape du dieu romain de la
médecine mais moi je ne le savais pas le
serpent d'esculable c'est très
certainement la couleur des culottes
juste ici extrêmement répandu à
l'Antiquité on accepte volontiers cette
couleur dans les palais dans les maisons
jusque dans les berceaux des bébés
paraît-il attendez-moi ça comme c'est
beau je voulais comprendre ce qui était
arrivé au serpent pendant les 20
dernières années et puis aussi pendant
les 20 derniers millions d'années et je
suis arrivé ici au Centre d'études
biologique de chizay pour rencontrer
Xavier bonnet l'un des plus grands
spécialistes mondiaux des serpents
mais bon c'est juste de les bouffe
ce site a été construit à l'origine pour
héberger une base militaire de l'OTAN
depuis on y trouve plus des militaires
mais des biologistes qui tentent de
comprendre les liens qui unissent les
différentes espèces au sein des
écosystèmes
en baladant j'ai vu des trucs de fou
j'ai vu des gens qui étaient en train de
découper des oiseaux marins pour voir
les parasites qu'ils avaient dans leur
intestins mais il y en a aussi qui
bossent sur les orques sur les
pollinisateurs on est un peu dans un des
hotspots de la compréhension de la
biodiversité mondiale
alors toi une question qui te passionne
sur les serpents c'est le l'évolution
elle est particulière elle est spéciale
celle des serpents les serpents ils
existent depuis
environ 150 millions d'années d'où
viennent les serpents c'est pas vraiment
on sait que ce sont des lézards et ils
ont perdu leurs pattes au cours du temps
ils se sont allongés très allongés puis
là on voit vraiment la caractéristique
des serpents aussi c'est la souplesse
[Musique]
alors la principale caractéristique
celle qui est la plus importante sur le
plan évolutif c'est le crâne il y a
quelques dizaines d'eau qui composent le
crâne ils sont plus ou moins articulés
les uns avec les autres ça donne une
grande flexibilité et donc notamment la
capacité d'engloutir de grosses proies
du coup ils ont une tête démentielle
c'est comme si non on pouvait manger des
hamburgers qui étaient grands comme ça
quoi alors en fait c'est comme si moi je
pouvais te manger sur le palais en haut
il y a plusieurs rangées dedans et
l'animal a tellement de mobilité qu'il
est capable de bouger ses dents les unes
par rapport aux autres et de faire
avancer le proie simplement en faisant
bouger ses dents et d'ailleurs ça porte
un nom ça s'appelle la marche des dents
[Musique]
alors on est en train de marcher dans la
forêt de Chizé pour essayer d'aller
chercher des serpents il y a des plaques
qui sont disséminées un petit peu
partout dans le paysage
on a installé à peu près plus de 1000
plaques quand on les soulève les
serpents se trouvent dessous parce
qu'ils viennent se réchauffer ou
chercher d'autres animaux qui se
trouvent de soins qui sont leurs proies
c'est un peu des zones de passage parce
qu'en soit trouver un serpent dans la
nature comme ça quand on marche c'est
super compliqué on en voit quand même
assez rarement et si on faisait ça en
fait à l'année qu'on n'avait pas de
plaque on devrait peut-être en attraper
une vingtaine alors que là on en a plus
de 500 à l'année
juste là
c'est une couleuvre à collier
[Musique]
alors ça c'est une petite couleur
d'Esculape qu'on a attrapé dans la
réserve biologique de Chizé alors le but
du jeu c'est de réussir à mesurer le
serpent je suis là il est constructeurs
donc il faut déjà le dérouler déjà en
plus elle a une sacrée force ce qui fait
que elle s'enroule très facilement alors
bien entendu vu qu'on travaille avec des
animaux vivants
faut toujours composer avec l'animal si
l'animal n'a pas envie c'est compliqué
donc du coup on va faire des mesures de
la longueur du corps comme on peut le
voir ici après on voit aussi prendre le
poids de l'animal et une fois que tu
l'as pesé tu mesures quoi on va faire
plein de mesures de tête et ça les
mesures biométriques c'est quelque chose
que font tous les herpétologues du monde
ouais tous les herpétologues du monde
vont faire ces mesures et en fait ça va
permettre de comparer un peu les
populations donc moi je disais c'est
quand même un truc le suivi de 30 ans
c'est quelque chose assez unique au
monde c'est vraiment avec ces bases de
données que vous arrivez à
à obtenir des résultats scientifiques
parce que sinon vous êtes aveugle si
vous avez passé
c'est que vu qu'on a énormément de
groupes qui travaillent sur les serpents
dans le monde entier si on travaille
tous de la même manière c'est plus
simple possible pour se comprendre
[Musique]
la beauté de ces mouvements ça fluidité
à inspirer artiste mythologies et tout
ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment extrêmement
fluide quand on tient on se demande
comment il se déplace d'ailleurs
c'est comme de l'eau qui coulevait à
l'envers ça force pas quand on a dans
les doigts ça force pas du tout et ça
avance il y a plein de serpent qui
veulent qu'on ait peur d'eux parce que
c'est souvent des proies en fait ouais
un serpent venimeux comme un cobra quand
il met son capuchon et quand il crache
c'est pour éviter une confrontation
c'est pas une position d'attaque ça pose
c'est pas du tout c'est une position de
bluff mais quand il chasse il fait pas
ça parce que s'il fait ça la preuve à
pas rester quand il chasse il change de
registre il est dans la discrétion pas
de bruit pas vu
alors ça c'est une espèce
semi-aquatique donc qui maîtrise très
bien la nage en surface la plongée elle
peut rester en apnée très longtemps sous
l'eau donc ceci est parfaitement à
l'aise dans l'eau mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que des espèces
terrestres donc
jamais évolué pour nager on les met dans
l'eau et assez rapidement et là je
remarquablement bien alors sur le
bandage ici ils essaient de comprendre
comment cette couleur par exemple
réussit à nager avec ses ondulations
donc tout le long du banc là ils mettent
des caméras pour avoir le plus de
données possible pour comprendre la
dépense énergétique du serpent la
vitesse
quels sont les muscles qui sont
impliqués et quel mouvement est réalisé
par le serpent c'est pas facile parce
que forcément c'est un animal qui a son
propre libre arbitre allez c'est pour la
science vas-y pépette vas-y montre à
l'heure
[Musique]
en France métropolitaine ce que les
serpents préfèrent c'est les milieux
ouverts comme ça mais leur mode de
locomotion leur a permis de conquérir
tous les milieux malgré leur
adaptabilité et ben les serpents partout
dans le monde morfle ça fait combien de
temps que tu dis les serpents 30 ans 30
ans et est-ce que en 30 ans tu l'as vu
l'effondrement de la biodiversité dont
on parle autant les fondament des
populations de serpent a pu la constater
mais c'est un drame en 30 ans à peine je
l'ai vu et je le vois donc dans un
espace de temps aussi court on voit le
sinistre se produire sous nos yeux parce
que l'homme impose un rythme une
violence de changement qui est vraiment
très très forte alors si on en fait une
petite liste à la Prévert il y a le
réchauffement climatique il y a les
déplacements d'espèces en numéro 1 de
très loin c'est la destruction des
habitats les serpents
comme leur proie comme tout un tas
d'animaux une grande partie de la
biodiversité ça prospère dans les zones
broussailleuses et de blocage et
pourquoi il y a des habitats des
cachettes enfin voilà c'est structuré
c'est complexe et donc s'entraîne
automatiquement une grande biodiversité
et un champ c'est pas complexe alors un
champ Type Beauchant de tournesol avec
des coquelicots de vent ça à peu près
autant d'intérêt qu'un parking de
supermarché quoi ça c'est un désert
donc quand on est en avion et qu'on voit
le l'espèce de mosaïque française du
paysage c'est des déserts des déserts
des déserts il y a des corridors quand
même pour eux circuler un peu non mais
c'est un désastre c'est la cause
principale de perte de biodiversité au
niveau mondial les gens ils sont
scandalisés par la déforestation pour le
l'huile de palme ou l'Amazonie mais chez
nous on fait pareil
dire les champs à perte de vue où il y a
des céréales et on nous explique que si
elle est empêche la culture ce qu'il
faut techniquement parlant c'est faux
c'est une folie c'est une folie de
destruction de mise à plat de la nature
toi si tu dis qu'il faut protéger la
biodiversité c'est pas tellement parce
que c'est utile mais l'argument
principal c'est c'est l'intérêt d'être
dans ce monde d'intérêt d'être vivant et
avec d'autres vivants la beauté les
gamins quand ils viennent dans la forêt
avec nous
j'ai jamais ce discours et derrière les
étudiants sont pas autorisés à la voir
faut protéger sa propre parce qu'ils
mangent les rongeurs et ça sauve les
cultures c'est quoi cette histoire où on
va avec ça mais les gamins c'est là
qu'il y a de l'espoir ils ont pas besoin
que leur dise que ça sert que ce soit
joli que ce soit merveilleux ça leur
suffit c'est quelque chose qui a été
oublié ça devrait nous suffire à nous
absolument effectivement il y a pas
besoin qui servent à quelque chose parce
que les tigres ils servent à rien on
peut les éliminer tous on vivra pareil
il y a pas besoin de baleine dans les
océans ça marchera autrement mais est-ce
que le monstre aussi joli sans tout ça
et c'est une partie de tes recherches de
faire des recommandations sur au pouvoir
public de leur dire quels sont les
points qui pourraient être améliorés en
termes de politique publique
typiquement nous ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est de combattre cette façon de
nettoyer d'aplatir la nature il faut
aménager du bordel c'est absolument si
vous avez des bosses et des creux vous
créez de la diversité et il y a des
options pour que la vie se cramponne
il y a des reflets iridescents sur les
sur les écailles de près c'est vraiment
magnifique
bon ben voilà je reste un peu flippé à
l'idée que mes enfants puissent tomber
un journée année avec une vipère ou un
serpent à sonnette mais je dois dire que
je suis encore plus flippé à l'idée
qu'il puisse grandir dans un monde dans
lequel il y en aurait pas après avoir
passé un siècle à vouloir tout gérer
tout contre les il serait peut-être
temps de laisser durablement de la place
au bordel parce que c'est dans le chaos
que la vie peut construire patiemment
son étrange est fascinante diversité je
crois qu'il est temps de se reconnecter
vraiment vivant et à tous les êtres
vivants pas que les pandas mignons
[Musique]